hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in the first few chapters of book two of
his work on anger Seneca is going to
introduce a process a three-stage
process by which anger develops within
us that has become probably one of the
most famous parts of this work it gets
talked about a lot in contemporary
literature in part because there's a
certain plausibility to it and it's
often taken as being the stoic point of
view if we look at other stoic thinkers
like Epictetus we can see and that may
be not the case but let's see what
Seneca himself has to say so he begins
by telling us that you know we have to
look at whether anger begins with an act
of judgment a eudicio which is also
going to be translated as deliberation
sometimes so it doesn't have to be like
a single act of judgment it could be a
process of judgment or whether it's
beginning with just an Impulse impetu
you know is it something that we are
ourselves involved in or is it just
things happening to us that make us
angry then and it's sort of out of our
control so this is a very important
question and he says is it set in motion
voluntarily or like many things that
come about inside us without us even
being aware you know when we have this
model of somebody pushing our buttons a
kind of mechanical model right it's sort
of like there's a stimulus and then
anger is the response and there's not
much that you can do about it you just
get angry and act on the anger maybe
reason is involved to some extent trying
to figure out how am I going to get that
bastard who did something to me but it's
definitely not running the show in any
important sense
so he tells us something really
important here anger is aroused moviat
it is it is brought into motion
by an appearance a species here in the
Latin and this is a very important
technical term for the stoics an
appearance in Greek is Fantasia which we
often translate also as impression it
also could be translated as imagination
and so what happens is something
something occurs and we see it we sense
it we think about it we respond to it we
identify it as being an instance of
something and what is the appearance the
appearance of somebody doing wrong in
urea in urea means not just injury but
like you know Injustice to us or it
could be to other people as well so he
says that
um you know when we think about this we
have the impression or the appearance
that we've been wronged now the question
is whether anger follow goes directly on
that appearance launching its attack
without the mind's collaboration or
whether it's stirred with the mind's
Ascent notice that he's not saying oh
it's all in your head you know nothing
outside of you actually took place there
isn't any real Injustice going on but
what contribution do we make to this
this is a very important question
because if we want to be able to manage
or control or even eliminate anger well
then we'd better have some agency we'd
better have some place where we can
actually do something about that so he's
going to talk about this process of
inference he says that anger Ventures
nothing on its own but it acts only with
the mind's approval why because having
the impression or the appearance that
somebody did wrong and so having or
literally taking taking that appearance
plus adding to this the the desire or
rather desire ring to take Vengeance for
it
right the very word that we see often
rendered as concupiscence right there's
a strong desire for
doing something that's retaliatory for
vindicating oneself so these get
combinedure is the word that he's using
there like little literally married
together into a judgment a eudicio and
what is that judgment well it's got two
sides to it one ought not to have been
harmed right there's a violation of some
sort of should debuise in the Latin
there and that one ought to be Avenged
vindicari one ought to be Vindicated
things ought to be put right so we've
got this entire process of inference
taking place there
and the question is well do we have any
role in it and Seneca thinks that we do
so he's going to set out these three
motions right and he'll talk about these
uh after giving some examples in uh
section four of this he says there's an
initial
involuntary movement right these three
movements to the past and the odd
factors of anger the movements the motor
right there's a first one this is not
voluntary and you notice that he does
use this language of the will or
volition quite a bit in this section he
also uses the term envitus which means
you know without one's consent or you
know just without one choosing it so
this first movement happens we're going
to look at that in just a moment uh he
calls this first
movement a preparation a preparation for
the passion and we should uh reflect on
the fact that he doesn't use the word
passio in most of these cases he uses
the word adfectus which you may also
recognize if you're aware of the Latin
as affectus right as an affection
something a bit broader than an emotion
specifically so we feel this this uh
preparation for it there's a threatening
single signal uh coma nazio right a
warning that something is is happening
and
you know this is uh where the first
beginnings of anger take place but this
is not yet anger Seneca wants to say
then we have a second movement which
we're going to look at a little bit he
calls this an expression of will come
voluntate it is with volition it is with
choice on our part not resolved
stubbornly known Contin
not being obstinate not resolving itself
foolishly in its uh point of view and he
says something very interesting here as
well
this is born from deliberation eudicio
again same term right is it uh beginning
with a judgment is it beginning with
deliberation so it's born from
deliberation and it can also be ended or
taken away tolore in Latin by that same
deliberation by something that we are in
control of and then we get to the third
uh movement and at this point reason is
gone right or if reason is working it's
solely in an instrumental way he says
that this is already out of control in
potens now you might say impotence that
means powerless right well it's
powerless with respect to the impulse of
anger it is already overthrown or
literally kicked out reason evicted
right and it has affirmed
as he's going to say the appearance
right so he says that it actually moves
by Will and judgment uh voluntate
eudicio towards Vengeance
ultionum the same Vengeance that was
talked about as being desired in that
inference right so we have these three
things first movement not in our control
second movement in our control third
movement also not in our control but for
different reasons because we took the
control or the capacity or the freedom
that we had and we threw it away by
collaborating with that first movement
and we wind up in the third movement and
now there's nothing we can really do at
that stage you could try to reason with
an angry person but if if it can
actually take hold of Seneca says well
they're not yet at this third place
they're in the second movement stage so
let's go back to the first one
it tells us that
um
there's all sorts of movements that
occur independent of our will and we
can't overcome them or avoid them what
are examples shivering when we're
sprinkled with cold water revulsion at
touching certain things the way our hair
stands on end at bad news the blush that
spreads when we hear obscene words the
dizziness that comes over us when we
look down a cliff these are all physical
reactions and can we control them at all
a little bit later he's going to say
that we cannot avoid that first mental
jolt with reasons help just as we cannot
avoid the other movements that befall
our bodies just as we cannot avoid
having another Yuan provoke our own
right or avoid closing our eyes at the
sudden poke of another's fingers reason
cannot overcome these movements
but perhaps their force can be lessened
if we become used to them and constantly
keep a watch for them this is where he
actually says that second movement
provoked by eudicio deliberation can be
overcome by it so you know when we see
things that we know are going to rile
ourselves up we can pay attention to
that and minimize those sorts of effects
and occasions and and what are these
well he goes on and he says
there's all sorts of things that
function to to get anger going we're
watching shows at theatrical games and
reading ancient history right we often
seem to become angry with Claudius as he
drives Cicero into Exile a very unjust
act that was going on carried out by an
unjust person against the person who is
reasonably just right when we see that
sort of thing we're starting to get
angry we're starting to get riled up you
could think about looking at stuff in
social media yeah and you see a report
about what those bastards are doing now
and you start getting angry about it
right
um what else he says that we uh who's
not stirred when faced with marius's
arms or Solo's prescription who doesn't
hate theodotus and achilles and the
actual child who dared a grown-up crime
I mean
us because we don't generally pay
attention to those people but you know
we can think about the people we see
depicted in television shows you know I
can't believe what happened in Westworld
or Game of Thrones or pick whatever else
you want right and all of these will be
behind us soon enough but people get
very very angry about that don't they so
these initial
um things he says sometimes a song sets
us on edge a double time tune the
Marshall sound of War trumpets a
horrific picture stirs our minds right
um and he gives some other examples you
know when we're with other people that
are smiling we smile back when we're
with mourners we feel sad and fear can
do this as well so he says these are not
passions but the first preludes to
Passion right and he says None of these
should be called passion uh they merely
chance to move the mind the mind doesn't
so much cause them as suffer them if I
can put it that way passion consists not
in being stirred in response to
Impressions presented to us but
in these other two stages in
surrendering ourselves to those
Impressions and following up the mind's
chance movement
so you know he gives an example of uh
turning pale or shedding tears the first
stirrings a sexual arousal a deep sigh a
suddenly sharpened glance anything along
these lines whoever reckons them a clear
token of passion and a sign of the
mind's engagement is mistaken and fails
to understand their bodily involuntary
movements it's when we collaborate with
them when we go along with them when we
involve as he's going to say
deliberation eudicio or Ascent a census
right or the will voluntas or Reason
itself the rational part of ourselves
razio that we start getting into trouble
in the second portion of this Dynamic of
anger
and so he says that
um you know
what we what we have the opportunity to
do is to take a stand against that anger
you know suppose someone as reckoned was
harmed wants to take revenge and
immediately calms down when some reason
may be supplied by himself or somebody
else
urges against it I don't call this anger
I call it the movement of a mind still
obedient to reason anger in its full
sense happens in this third movement
right he says uh anger something that
leaps clear of reason that snatches
reason up and carries it along
so what is really anger uh the
intentional movement that follows which
is not only taken in the impression but
affirmed it and then we get to this
stage where it's it's you know not just
affirming it but has affirmed it that's
anger the arousal of a mind that moves
willingly and deliberately with you know
as as we said uh will and judgment
towards Vengeance so these are the three
stages here and what this means is that
we actually have considerable
control or opportunity for control if we
actually practice it if we don't allow
it to get to this third
movement third stage where we've
actually lost control and now we're just
going to be subject to it so three main
movements three main stages to how anger
develops for Seneca and this is not just
for anger this is also for other
emotions as well